twenty-one seasons in the National
Hockey League he was known as the
Finnish flash and he's one of the best
to ever lace them up and we're on on
angels Radio AM 8:30 right in the heart
of Anaheim Ducks country every single
day so we're thrilled to have one of the
all-time great Ducks when the old-time
great players not just in the NHL but
internationally his new book my life is
available we're all books are sold good
to see you Teemu selänne how are you sir
I know you're doing great
just to update our radio audience that
missed what we just witnessed on our
television side we played the isin game
on the Callaway corner where the maximum
number of putts you can make as as five
for the maximum points of 14 you drained
them all sir that's lucky oh gosh you
put all the biscuits in the basket over
there
what is your what's your handicap it's
like I'm about three now when you say
it's about three it's all depends who I
play against to say yeah are you trying
to be you know cagey about it cuz you
don't want to let everyone know how how
many how much candy you can give one
handicap and sure 78 okay I want to be
three who shoot even par okay and you
look like you've got a nice tan going so
it looks like you've got the golf game
with regularity right no I played tennis
or golf pretty much every day no kidding
yeah what's your tennis game looks like
what that means game is I like tennis
even more not than golf you know it's
love tennis and it's a good workout and
I don't really work out there any any
more so that is my thing right now do I
tell them about my tennis do I tell them
I'm talking to one of the best athletes
internationally there's a rosette in a
chair keep it brief okay I'll keep it
brief I've been taking up tennis myself
lately I'm 50 how old are you I'm gonna
be a 50 next year you're gonna be 50
next year so we're the same age do we
look the same age Chris - you okay -
stop
stop I shouldn't ask questions okay I'm
getting a little bit of plantar
fasciitis on my on my on my left foot
because of tennis do you feel that a
little bit you know what is hard hard
sport for your body but you're feeling
it you're good you're good okay and uh
all right so that's where the
similarities are not even where it's not
kind of a Venn diagram here and in term
what's your speed on your serve how fast
my service my weakest point in my game
uh-huh it's probably like maybe 110 now
we're talking miles per hour Mama's
gonna make sure yeah it's serious team
that's some serious serve that you got
right no it's not I think the guys who I
play against I'm the worst server but
well come on now who do you play you get
are you playing against real like
professional tennis player I play a
couple like International Tennis
Federation over 45 a league okay and
tournaments in Europe in the summer time
so I try to take that to another level
but I don't think my body can take the
whole practice training I just play for
fun tell me about it I mean I know what
you're talking about that's why I don't
you know I'm not touring in Europe on
summertime either because you know my
left foot I got plantar fasciitis or two
but Teemu selänne here on the Rich Eisen
show again my life will of this book was
originally put out in your native
Finland correct 2014 okay and now why'd
you decide to put it in English and put
it on a lot of people were asking about
that and leave a little I I got the idea
that maybe it would be nice it's gonna
last forever and it's something but you
know I think the people are interested
is to read my journey and it was 21
years in NH here but it's not only about
hockey it's about life and up up and
downs and I'm pretty excited about it
okay so um when's the first time you
laced up when would you remember that
first time you ever put on a pair of
skates I think I was like 5 years old 5
years old hockey's the biggest thing and
and all the little kids and and girls to
play hockey this there's at least some
point ok and so when did you realize
that you had a special skill
for it well I was always fast and a lot
of passion for any sports pretty much
but I think not until I was 17 I
realized I'm better than other guys and
you're a year later I got drafted in NHL
and then it has been just climbing a
higher well I mean what you still have
the record for most goals and points by
a rookie 76 goals your first season I
mean at some point were you even
surprising yourself I didn't realize
what I did until like three years after
you know but you know I wasn't very
lucky when I went there the table was
set up for me I got right away a chance
to play with the best players and and
first power play and and you know the
confidence what I had it was almost like
snowball going down the hill I just kept
more and more and I got hungry or hunger
and he was amazing amazing journey that
first year especially well did you think
Melissa this NHL things easy did you
think that at that point not really but
I was shocked that I was able to do so
many goals and play well in 76 there's a
certain number so after that by numbers
my career went downhill
so only Gretzky Lemieux and Brett Hull
have scored more yeah in terms of that
that's amazing
best player ever played with would be
who team drew Salani for myself maybe
Paul Kariya but I was lucky that I
played all my career with the crazy
players and I got the chance to play
with Koretsky in the same line the
all-star game and what was that like you
know I was honored you know I always had
a he's a picture in my wall when I was a
young guy and I always remember at 91
Canada Cup I played the team feeling
against Canada first game in old Maple
Leaf garden and and in the face of he's
right beside me and I that was
nerve-wracking you know I didn't know
how to act you know right but if I see
no great feeling and realize that I'm
playing the same league than my hero you
know that I mean that you're you're on
the same line as well I know dream come
true for sure and he's just one of the
nicest guys he's just like a great human
being
unbelievable what he has done not only
on the ice but after eyes you know it
it's on touch you know like we are very
lucky that we have had a guy like him
for hockey so who was the nastiest guy
that you ever oh by far stronger he was
a beast that guy and I always hated to
play again he's even stutter you just
think you pulled pronger right out right
there huh yeah but you know he's six six
and big boy and but you know what 2006
you know we became the teammates and
year after we won the Stanley Cup
together and great teammate and good guy
and it was fun to be his friend so Teemu
selänne here on the Rich Eisen show look
people who are a hardcore supposedly you
know like let's just say NHL fans the
original six right like the old school
places think of Southern California is a
lightweight hockey area because we all
have beaches and it's 80 degrees outside
you have performed here in Southern
California more than most it's an
intense hockey community that's down
here in Southern California I would love
for you to put a little bit of more meat
on those bones what do you think
absolutely I think you know when kritzky
game came in LA I think he started that
boom about hockey I think he's the
reason why we got the teams in Anaheim
and San Jose and little by little that
you know hockey has really crawled here
a lot you know and Ducks and kings and
and and sharks that they didn't great
job with the youth program and you know
I think hockey really became a big big
sport here you know and obviously Kings
want to Stanley Cups and Ducks want so I
think those are so much help for hockey
here and you know I love when my
favorite thing in after the practice
when I good practice and you go ma you
go out and it's 80 degrees and right you
see the palm trees and it's just awesome
when I first moved out here Teemu
Selanne here on the Rich Eisen show I
was I lived on the East Coast my whole
life and I was on ESPN for a long time
and was up there in Bristol Connecticut
and then I moved out here for the NFL
Network and we worked like crazy and I
was inside all the time
and inside you know chili sets and I
would walk outside I'm like man I can't
believe I'm missing this day and then it
dawned on me the next day the next day
and the next day is just like that and
it's really it's just a I do love living
around out here yeah we get so spoiled
here not the Sun and the light you know
let's give you energy on every day every
morning when you wake up and you look
outside yeah you just make it makes you
happy
so a couple more minutes here with Teemu
Selanne on the Rich Eisen show who would
you peep who would you pay money to see
play hockey today in today's NHL you
know what I think then today's NHL is so
special because every team has
unbelievable hockey players so about the
you know what like guys like Connor
McDavid you know like I love what him
playing why he's so fast and quick and
and every time when he's on the ice
something great happens you know an but
like I said every team has those players
right now Matt Barse all New York
Islanders I love how he plays of course
we have all the guys Sidney Crosby and
those guys so I think the hockey's doing
really really good right now and it's
fun to watch you know it's kind of
freaks me out here you refer to Sidney
Crosby in one of the older guys well
he's getting there it's amazing it
really is amazing what was it like being
around Lemieux whenever you were on him
or yogur walk me through those guys you
know what the great thing about hockey
you know that I haven't met bad guy in
hockey and you know they all create guys
and very humble guys I mean like when he
talked about Mario he never make any any
big number of himself and he always
talked about highly about everybody so
those guys are really through
gentlemen's you know and they're good
role models and that's why I I think
people love hockey players because they
are down-to-earth guys and they don't
have any egos you know it's just and
it's easy to go talk to the Hardy flash
either well I mean I also remember when
you stepped away from from hockey and
everybody got together on the ice
started banging the sticks for you yeah
I it was a really moving moment and I'm
wondering what it was like for you when
you realized okay 21 seasons I've been
there I've done that I've done so much
and then you had your own peers
banging sticks on the ice for you what
was that like a thrust
you know I be Conner you know obviously
we just lost game 7 against
Kings right which is our our really
really rivalry team and and all the
Kings players stayed on the eyes and and
they were clapping their sticks and you
know it's just like something that we
are so United as a hockey players even
you know there's a lot of battles
between two teams but the appreciation
and the honor what we feel to each other
you know it's something that you don't
see that very very often so it was a
special moment and I try to play the
game fair and and you know I don't
really have any enemies and what
happened on the ice you know happening
on the ice and then off the ice you know
you want to be a good guy and right
respectful for everybody did you ever
not want to shake somebody's hand after
no obviously you never know never once
no even those tough guys when they
dropped the club Sunday they'd try to
beat each other you know after the games
they go have a beer that's that's
awesome either even Claude Lemieux you
want to shake yourself absolutely he was
good to me it's one of the old-time
favorite lines
yeah was at Draper we told her that said
that or it's yeah I think those two guys
yeah right shake his freaking hand so
before I let you go you said this books
more than about hockey it's about life
what do you mean by that well you know I
think everybody's life there's up and
downs and I talk about my you know my
families and my parents and divorce and
and my older brothers drug problems and
and pretty much everything I try to be
very honest about what has happened
clearly yeah and you know it's I really
believe that when you come out with the
book you know it's it's a kid to tell
everything you know and it's about
journey that what has happened and and
how I felt about different things so
check it all out Teemu selänne my life
we're all books are sold thrilled to
have you here on the show I mean just in
terms of the 21 seasons 10 time all-star
rookie there you got the Calder Trophy
maurices rocket Rashard trophy for the
leading scorer one year most points as
mentioned by a rookie and goals by a
rookie with all this player to win a
medal in Olympic hockey at 43 years old
so I asked this with the utmost of
humility where
does having a perfect score in the Eisen
game that you had during our television
only segment all that's off of the list
where does that rank team in Iraq right
in the top because I think the golf is
the hardest sport in earth and I really
believe that I was created a sleep on
the until I start playing golf so I have
to put that number one okay great I
appreciate you saying that you're not
just saying that because you're sitting
next okay very good I really appreciate
that there is no I in team ooh or Salani
there's a lot of other vowels thank you
for coming on this show team thanks for
having about Teemu Selanne right here
check him out on twitter and also on
instagram at salon ET mu but the the a
the a is an eight on its are you are you
were out there posting yourself you're
absolutely okay very good
everything by the way uh-huh it looks
Chris and again just tell me just for
all the radio artists looks like you
could give me a few shifts right now
like right now you can give me a show
many shifts can you give me right now
zero like in the NHL like if we three
out there well of course you know I mean
ships can talk about that you keep me
three months and I can play in it no
come on come on yeah like it's a break
get this tweet up you raking news you
three months like right now if we've
it's November what are we in November
sixth right now Teemu Selanne announces
comeback by February sixth right after
the Super Bowl team with Salonika got
and helped me like you like what
homestretch top star of the night second
star the night for sure one of them okay
yeah okay you know I just to say to I
could too if it wasn't for my plantar
fascia I'd be out there thanks Tina
that's Teemu selänne right here guys to
show we're back with more animal
[Music]
four more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app